cuando aprendo una nueva aplicación de
las combinaciones y que al principio
puede ser no muy intuitiva y que después
de reflexionar un tiempo empieza a ser
sentido y te permite apreciar una vez
más la belleza de las matemáticas y
sabes por qué decimos tomar las
combinaciones de ka nn y le llamamos el
coeficiente binomial porque ahora vamos
a tratar el teorema del binomio y antes
de tratar el teorema del binomio te
quiero platicar porque es interesante
empezaremos borrando la pantalla así que
borrar e invertir colores
si quisiéramos multiplicar por ejemplo
las potencias de un binomio un binomio
es un polinomio de dos términos cierto
así que a más b al a cero es igual a uno
a más ve a la cero es igual a uno a más
b a la 1a más vea la 1 es igual a más b
a v al cuadrado bueno si no tienes mucha
experiencia con esto es probable que
pienses que esa cuadra damas b cuadrada
pero rápido corregirá estos pensamientos
y en alguna región de tu mente
recordarás que esto lo podemos escribir
como a más b por a más b y si utilizamos
la propiedad distributiva que bien
recordarás de otros cursos esto queda a
veces a más b más veces a más b lo que
es igual a a cuadrada más a b más ve a
más b cuadrada y eso es igual a cuadrada
más 2 ave más b cuadrada y puede
servirte como una revisión esto es
además b al cuadrado es interesante y lo
vamos a remarcar ahora veamos qué es
a más ve a la tercera a más ve al cubo
esto empieza a ponerse complicado es
igual a más veces a más ve veces a a más
o lo podríamos ver como a más b al
cuadrado por a más b la tercera potencia
y si esto es a más ve al cuadrado si lo
multiplicamos ahora más b obtendremos
además ve al cubo así que hagámoslo
vamos a multiplicar por a b y este vamos
a utilizar un otro color y entonces
empezamos multiplicando todo por ver que
sería a cuadrada por b es cuadrada b2b
por b es 2a b cuadrada 2a b por b y
luego tenemos b cuadrada por beckett b
kubica ahora lo vamos a hacer con una a
por a cuadrada es al cubo más 2 ave por
a ser a 2 a cuadrada veces y eso es lo
que es 2a cuadrada b ahora vamos a
multiplicar de cuadrada por a
y eso nos va a dar
cuadrada y ahora vamos a sumar todos los
términos y agrupar todo lo que tenemos
aquí que ya hicimos
entonces empezamos y tenemos una al cubo
que aquí la pongo y luego vamos a juntar
los términos con a cuadrada b y aquí
tenemos un 2 aquí tenemos otro entonces
si lo escribo aquí abajo lo sumo si lo
voy a pasar aquí para que esté más claro
y entonces ahora tenemos 3 a cuadrada b
lo siguiente el término con ave cuadrada
aquí tenemos 1 con 2 y 1 y entonces es
tres veces ave cuadrada más de kubica
que ese término está solo
ya tenemos lo que corresponde a más ve
al cubo y podríamos si tuviéramos
obviamente el tiempo saber cuánto es más
ve a la cuarta o por ejemplo oa más ve a
la 10 pero estarás de acuerdo conmigo
que eso tomaría todo el día no sería
mejor tener una idea de cómo desarrollar
esto sin hacer tantas operaciones
y justo aquí es donde entra el juego el
teorema del binomio en este vídeo te voy
a mostrar de qué se trata el teorema de
binomio cómo funciona algunos trucos y
vas a ver vas a parecer un genio
trabajando con estas cosas en otros
vídeos haremos unos ejercicios te daré
la intuición acerca del teorema del
binomio y también veremos cuál es su
relación con las combinaciones después
de aprender el teorema del binomio tal
vez tú quieras comprobar que
efectivamente funciona y no sé tal vez
calculará ambas ve a la cuarta otra
potencia y bueno sería una especie como
del ejercicio rudo para mejor
continuemos
y bien lo que dice el teorema del
binomio es que a más ve a la n
va a ser igual aunque se ve un poco
complicado pero vamos con calma va a ser
más ve a la n va a ser la suma
de acá igual a cero hasta n estã n que
está aquí la misma de este lado y los
términos va a ser las combinaciones de n
tomados en cada
y luego los términos que viene va a ser
de x a la n - k x que a la k y bueno se
ve un poco complicado pero vámonos con
calma
pronto observarás como este concepto
tiene sentido avancemos pero primero
déjame revisar hoy aquí cometió un error
este tiene que ser a él de este lado
pues tiene que ser b porque en todo caso
tendría que haber puesto x más pero no
son ahí ve claro bueno las letras no son
tan importantes lo importante es el
concepto y es válido con ahí veo con xy
pero vamos a un ejemplo este déjame ver
es que vamos a hacer que sea
+ b y este binomio lo vamos a elevar a
la que te parece a la cuarta sin la
cuarta potencia
qué es lo que nos dice el teorema así
que lo primero que vamos a hacer es que
aquí n tiene el valor de 4 y será la
suma de cada igual a 0 hasta 4 de las
combinaciones de 4 tomado en cada
d
a la 4 - que ve a la k
hagamos el desarrollo del teorema así
que lo que sigue sería el primer término
es cuando cada vale cero asia que serían
las combinaciones de cuatro tomadas en
cero de a a la 4 - 0 que es a la 4ª x b
a la 0 que bueno ve a la 0 es 1 o sea
que nada más queda a la cuarta a eso le
vamos a sumar ahora acá vale 1 entonces
las combinaciones de 4 tomado en uno de
cuatro menos uno esa nos queda a las
tres y ve a la 1 entonces ahora aquí
ponemos ve a la 1 algo que podríamos ir
observando es como el primer término
empieza con un número que va de cree
mentando pse es decir la potencia inicia
y se van incrementando en 1 y el segundo
término comienza en potencia 0 y va
incrementándose en 1 hasta llegar a la
potencia la que estamos desarrollando
siguiendo con el patrón ahora tendremos
las combinaciones de cuatro tomada en 2d
al cuadrado b al cuadrado más las
combinaciones de cuatro tomado en 3d a
por ver al cubo y después las
combinaciones de cuatro tomada en 4 d
a la 0 porque aquí es 4 menos 4 entonces
nos queda uno ve a la cuarta observemos
con cuidado cómo se van formando los
coeficientes y cómo funciona el teorema
del binomio así que veamos la forma
general y vamos revisando la paso a paso
así que primero lo que lo voy a indicar
y recordemos que las combinaciones de n
tomados en k es igual a n factorial
dividido entre k factorial que
multiplica a n menos k factorial
y entonces ahora vayamos con nuestro
ejemplo así que si toma las
combinaciones de cuatro tomado en cero
esto va a ser aquí arriba va a ser
cuatro claro que si va a ser un cuatro
factorial dividido entre cero factorial
que multiplica a 4 - 0 o sea que es 4
factorial a la cuarta y ve a la cero es
uno más cuatro factorial dividido entre
uno factorial aquí va a ser tres
factorial
por a la tercera
orbe el siguiente término serán
bueno vamos a separarlo para que se vea
mejor sería 4 factorial
dividido entre 2 factoriales y 4 menos
12 2 así que es 2 factorial que
multiplica al cuadrado b cuadrada el
siguiente término va a ser otra vez en 4
factorial ahora dividido entre 3
factorial por 1 factorial y aquí es
orbe al cubo el que sigue será 4
factorial sobre 4 factorial por 0
factorial ve a la cuarta así que este
coeficiente es igual a este este
coeficiente será igual a éste y este
pues está solo
y ahora hagamos las cuentas así que aquí
abajo tenemos 0 factorial 0 factoriales
1 bueno si no lo sabías así que nos
queda 4 factorial que es 4 por 3 por 2
por 1 pero dividido por ello mismo así
que es un 1 simplemente nos queda a la
cuarta más este término es 4 factorial 4
por 3 por 2 por uno dividido entre 3 por
2 por 1 nada más nos queda un 4 así que
es 4 veces al cubo ve el siguiente
término como dijimos 4 factoriales 4 por
3 por 2 x así que tenemos 4 x de 3 12
por 2 24 abajo 2 factoriales simplemente
2 2 por 2 son 4 así que estos 4 24 entre
4 y 6 al cuadrado de cuadrada más este
término y este otro término van a ser
idénticos pues están divididos por lo
mismo y nos dará que resulta en 4 o sea
que aquí tenemos 1
ve al cubo y además tiene sentido que
haya una simetría ahora bueno si te
parece confuso pues no me hagas mucho
caso y si te parece iluminador pues
maravilloso así que tenemos 4 a b al
cubo y el último término pues será 4
factorial dividido entre 4 factorial
pues es igualito a este otro término así
que nada más nos queda ve a la cuarta
los coeficientes son entonces 1 464 y 1
eje más adelante en otro vídeo veremos
que corresponden también al triángulo de
pascal pero bueno ese es otro tema y
también haremos muchísimos más
ejercicios con el teorema del binomio
por lo pronto yo creo que ya se me está
terminando el tiempo y nos vemos en el
siguiente